The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, we're
going to be talking about
today and on Thursday, we're
going to be trying to answer
this question.
We're going to give a slightly
different answer
today than on Thursday.
Just to give you a road map of
where we are going, today is
more going to be about the
poverty trap in the sense that
Pak Solhin described
it to us in--
I think it was our first
lecture together.
We started from Pak Solhin
description of a poverty trap,
which was really based on the
immediate impact of the
calories on your productivity
that very day.
And then that's what we're going
to look at today, which
is try to answer
[? Daiquiri's ?]
question which I've been putting
off until now, which
is to say well, can we really
believe his story?
And then on Thursday, we are
going to further our inquiry
into nutrition based poverty
trap by looking at things a
little bit more subtle than the
impact of calories on your
productivity the very next day
by looking at things like
micro nutrients and by looking
at things like feeding your
children or feeding pregnant
mother so that the kids that
they bear grow up as different
people, et cetera.
So that's kind of the road
map for our work
today and on Thursday.
At the end of last lecture,
we discussed the important
observation by Amartya Sen
that maybe there are no
famines in today's democracies,
that the large
big famines are gone or at least
that when we observe
them, they are due to some
really extraordinary
circumstances like a
war or a civil war.
So there is a paper that I
didn't ask you to read because
it's a little long.
But the title is Is
Famine History?
And it sort of concludes that
it might be outside of
specific circumstances.
I should say that it's history
that might come back because
we have no idea what global
warming is going to do to the
productivity of agriculture,
and it may or may not be
sufficiently bad that
it might come back.
But in the short term, we may be
in a situation where people
are not starving to death in
very large number like they
did in West Mongol outside
of some big
serious political crisis.
However, malnutrition and
under nutrition is not.
You can see the food and
agriculture organization
that's based in Rome is in
charge of trying to monitor
people's situation.
They try to estimate how many
people are, they call, hungry.
So they give periodically a
number of the number of hungry
people in the world.
And not long ago, they came
up with one billion.
And that number, if you've seen,
has been all about the
newspaper, one billion hungry
people in the world.
To be completely honest, I am
not fully understood how they
compute the number of hungry
people in the world, because I
suppose you could ask them.
But I don't think this is
what they are doing.
I think they are trying to
estimate the calorie
requirement that people
might need to fit.
And the question is do we really
know what's a calorie
requirement?
And the answer to that is no.
We don't really exactly know
what's a calorie requirement.
So maybe this notion of what's
a hungry person is a little
bit more hazy than we'd
like it to be.
But there is not really
a lot of people
who look very skinny.
So do you know what the
bodymass index?
The bodymass index is your--
sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: 730 times your
height divided
by your weight squared.
PROFESSOR: 730?
I didn't know that that's 730.
I think it's your weight
divided by your
height squared in meter.
That's maybe the 730
coming from.
It's your weight in kilograms
divided by your height in
meter squared.
So sometimes I'm trying to think
that this means that
we're trying to elongate the
person over a square meter and
see how fat that rectangle
would be.
So that's the BMI.
Do you know what the threshold
for the BMI is.
AUDIENCE: 18.5.
PROFESSOR: 18.5.
So 18.5 is undernourished.
And there is a large number
of people we know who are
undernourished by
this standard.
Also there is about 2 billion
people in the
world who are anemic.
That means they don't
have enough
hemoglobin in their blood.
Now all of anemia is due to
poor nutrition, but it's
estimated that maybe half
of this is due to
iron deficiency anemia.
So it's a deficiency
in one particular
micronutrient which is iron.
So that's about one billion
people who are anemic due to
some deficiency in iron
in their diet.
Is there deficiency in
iron or difficulty in
absorbing the iron?
A lot of these anemic
people is in India.
And sadly, Indians combine the
fact that many of them are
vegetarian and their diet is
rich in rice which is rich in
phytates, which is an inhibitant
for the absorption
of iron, which is one reason
why the rate of anemia is
particularly high in India, is
that on the one hand, they get
less iron in their diet than
other people at comparable
level of calorie intake
just because those
come less from meat.
Then on the other hand, they
are less good at absorbing
them due to the rice.
There was a large increase
in food prices in 2006.
And then again, they collapsed
during the crisis.
And they increased again
in 2010 to be
almost at 2008 level.
And there are two consequences
of an increase in food prices
on those of the poor who are net
consumer of food, that is
those who produce less
than they consume.
Those are, for example,
the urban poor.
And those are on the one hand,
a large proportion of the
budget of the poor.
A larger proportion of the
budget of the poor is spent on
food, so an increase in the
price of food affect the
poorest more than
proportionally, compared to
any other source of inflation.
So if the source of inflation is
sort of a general increase
in priced or it's driven by
the price of housing, then
that affects everybody the
same or that might
affect the rich more.
But if the inflation is as
it is today, driven by an
increase in the price of food,
then it affects more the
people who are relying the
most, of course, on food.
And that's the first story.
That's one reason why
organizations like the World
Bank, the UN, they FAO are
practically worried about an
increase in food prices,
because that's
disproportionately affecting
the poor.
And it's also disproportionately
affecting
the urban poor, which may be one
of the many reasons that
have led to the unrest that
you observe today in the
Middle East.
The reason why I'm mentioning
that is that in 2008, at the
height of the previous increase
in food prices, there
were food riots in Egypt that
never had achieved the kind of
intensity of what we saw in the
last few weeks, but were
clearly and very directly
prompted by the price of food.
And here, the whole rhetoric
of the revolt was framed
around political reform, but it
is not impossible that part
of the reason why so many
people, in particular in urban
centers, were willing to
spending so much time outside
protesting is because they were
profoundly unhappy with
the increase in the
price of food.
The second reason why we might
be worried about an increase
in the price of food is if we
take Pak Solhin's story
seriously and we are wondering
that this increase in hunger
is going to lead to some
vicious circle.
So If you read the World
Bank document about--
the World Bank's job, in a
sense, is to raise money for
developing countries.
So part of the World Bank's
communication department job
is to be slightly alarmist, so
we need to take everything
they say with a pinch of salt.
But one of the thing that they
would very frequently say is
the price of food increase--
that makes the poor poorer.
That makes them more difficult
for them to get enough
calories, which means they
can't work as hard, which
means they will be plunged
back into poverty.
And so this is the story that
Pak Solhin told us in our
first lecture.
And that's what I want to
investigate with you today,
whether we have reasons to be
worried about this kind of
immediate vicious circle.
So I want to give us a quick
refresher of what's Pak
Solhin's story.
So with your daily wage, it's
a short term nutrition, a
nutrition based poverty trap.
With your wage, you buy food.
That gives you strength, and
allows you to get some more
wages at the end.
So you buy more food, and
that gives you strength.
And you have more wages,
et cetera.
And that's how you survive
maybe on a daily basis.
So that means that it creates
a relationship between how
much you start from one fine
evening and what is your
income tomorrow.
And that also means that it
creates a relationship with
the wage level and your ability
to do any work at all.
So Pak Solhin's story was that
the wage had dropped because
of the increase in input prices
and the uncertainty
that the farmer had about
whether they were going to be
able to raise their output
prices corresponding.
That had led to a decrease in
the wage at the same time as
there was an increase in the
food prices, so big decrease
in the real wage in term of the
food entitlement of a day
of work as Amartya Sen would
say, which means that if you
took this food entitlement and
you had nothing else to
supplement it with, this just
was not enough to give you the
strength to do the work
to earn that wage.
So that means that someone like
Pak Solhin that had no
extra resources was not
able to work at all.
So that creates an inequality
among people.
Take Pak Solhin and imagine
that, in fact, he also had a
little piece of land.
Then what could he have done
with this little piece of land
once the wages had gone down?
Ben?
AUDIENCE: Sell some of it.
PROFESSOR: So he could have sold
some of it to get money.
Or he could have rented some
of it and get money.
So suppose he rents some
of it and gets money?
So he starts the morning with
1000 rupee he has from the
rent of his field.
And that can be complimented
with whatever wage he's earned
yesterday for his work.
And that might be enough to give
him the strength to do a
day of work.
So if you compare Pak Solhin to
his brother, for example--
he has a brother in
the story, right?
If you compare Pak Solhin with
his brother, who had a piece
of land, they might be exactly
similar in term of their
underlying body and their
strength, et cetera.
But the fact that one of them
has a piece of land allow them
to work, and therefore they
start with a little bit more
non-labor income, which gives
them much more labor income.
So the existing inequality
in non-labor income is
strengthened by the inequality
in labor income, which is very
different from what we would
see in our standard models
where the richer people would be
less likely to work because
they already have the non
labor income money.
So the labor market would serve
to make people more
similar rather than
less similar.
So that's the story
he told us.
And as we saw last time, the
necessary condition for such a
poverty trap is that the
capacity curve, which relates
your income to that, your
income tomorrow via the
biology of the body, has this
S shape curve that we
discussed that intersects below
the 45 degree line, then
at some point crosses it
and then comes back.
So we are not going to go back
to that, because we saw it in
detail last time.
That was supposed to
be the shape again.
It doesn't want to come back.
So the S shape is made
of two relations.
The S shape is the relationship
between income
today and income tomorrow,
midrow since I can't have it
on the slide.
So this is income today
and income tomorrow.
And so the S shape is actually
not one function, it's the
product of two functions.
One is given how much income you
have, how much calories do
you decide to eat?
And then the calorie
that you eat--
how much productive
do that make you?
So if we write it in math, it's
like there is income,
nutrition is equal to g,
function g of income today.
Because you get your wages and
then you eat some good meal.
And then income tomorrow is
a function f of nutrition.
That means that income
tomorrow is f
of g of income today.
So this is what makes
this S shape.
So what we can do today is to
look separately at these two
relationships.
What's the strength of the
relationship between income
tomorrow and nutrition today?
And what's the relationship
between nutrition today and
income today?
And here, when I mean today and
tomorrow, I really mean
today and tomorrow.
This is a short run phenomenon
that we are talking about.
Maybe next week, but
not a matter of
generations or years.
So suppose that there is indeed
that this particular
relationship, income tomorrow
and nutrition, is indeed S
shape, and suppose that you were
a very poor person, so
you are in a low part of the S,
and suppose that you happen
onto a bit of money, what would
you do with this money?
If this relationship between
income and nutrition was S
shape and you were a very poor
person, but you find a pile of
money on the ground, what would
you do with the money?
AUDIENCE: Well, if that
holds true, then you
would want to eat more.
PROFESSOR: If that holds
true, then I know you
would want to eat more.
So that means that if there is
indeed an S shape between
income tomorrow and nutrition,
then we should see a very
strong relationship between
nutrition and income for the
very poor, because it is like
for an excellent investment.
If you find yourself here, there
is no better investment
you can do than eating
some more.
So a first thing you can do is
we can see whether poor people
are really trying to
put all of the
possible money into food.
Now the question is the possible
money, so that means
that we would find the share of
food in the budget should
be very high for the poor.
And the second thing it would
mean is that it would increase
quite fast with income.
And possibly, it would again
have a form of S shape for the
following reason.
Suppose that you have some
unavoidable expense to solve.
For example, you need a house
and you need some clothes.
So unless you live in a very
hot country where you don't
really need much clothes, you
need a house, you need a piece
of land to put the house on,
and you need some clothes.
So someone who was a budget of
20 rupees will spend, say,
five rupees on clothing
and house.
They can't do anything
more than that.
And 15 rupees on food.
So that's the poorest person.
And then if there is really this
S shape here, this person
would be somewhere here.
So they would remain
quite poor.
And now another person,
comparable in other aspect,
but has a total budget of 30
rupees, let's say because they
have some non labor income or
because they have a bit more
weight, than they would still
spend unavoidable expenses on
clothing and houses, but they
would not do any more.
They will still do
just the minimum.
And they would spend all
the rest on food.
That means that by how much did
I increase the income of
this person?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: By 10.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 10 out of
20, and [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: 50%
PROFESSOR: 50%, and this is
how much of [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's 25 out of 15.
An increase from 15 to 25.
It's 10 on the basis of 15.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I trust you.
You are the MA student.
So whatever it is, that's
going to be on video.
66?
Let's go with 66.
That means that when I increase
your income by 50%,
your expenditure on food
increases by 66%.
So if I divide by one
of the other, what
concept is it called?
An elasticity.
So this means the elasticity
of food expenditure with
respect to overall expenditure
is more than one for the
extremely poor.
Because you start by
taking care of
your essentially needs.
And after that you're putting
all of the money into food
because you think this
is highly valuable.
So this is one thing.
And the second thing is now you
go from someone who gets
30 rupees to someone
who gets 45 rupees.
So I've rigged this so
that it's nicely
another increase of 50%.
And now this person who
makes 45 rupees--
they're already kind of over
here somewhere, so the
marginal value of one
more rupees into
food is not that high.
So they are still going to spend
a bit more on food, but
only five rupees more.
Going to spend a bit more
to have a nicer
clothing and some houses.
And now they can bring in
entertainment, because now
they are basically just
taken care of.
The marginal value of extra
is not that high.
So they can get into
doing other things.
So now the elasticity is
going to be 0.25 to 30.
That's out of 25.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: 20%
PROFESSOR: 20%, is that?
Yes, 20%.
20% out of an increase in 50%.
Now the elasticity is
much less than 1.
So what we would see is a group
of people, the poorest
people, where we have very
high elasticity.
And then for anybody who
is somewhat richer, the
elasticity of food consumption
with overall budget would be
less than 1, which is what
people refer to as the Engel
curve, which is the share of
food of the budget increases
less than proportionately.
So the Engel curve refers to
this phenomenon, which is the
share of food increases less
than proportionately as you
become richer, but it's worth
pointing out that in an S
shaped world, we would probably
have and reverse
Engel curve phenomenon, where
the share of food of the
budget first increases
and then decreases.
So the question is, do we see
this, that the poor spend as
much money as they
can on food?
And the second question is, do
we see this, which is do we
see anybody who's elasticity
of food consumption with
respect to budget
is more than 1?
So that's kind of where
I want to go next.
So first, let's look at the
food share in the budget
around the world.
And this comes from
a data set that--
the World Bank collect data set
in many countries called
the Living Standard Measurement
Surveys.
And they very nicely put
them on the website--
not all of their surveys,
because in some case, they
have agreement with governments
that doesn't allow
them to do that.
But a lot of their surveys
are on the web.
You can actually download
them and play with them.
You're welcome to do that.
And we did that.
So we took the overall
expenditure to compute
people's budget transferred
into PPP dollars.
So this is people who live
under a dollar a day, at
pressures in power poverty,
so in US prices.
And look at the share
of their budget.
So this is what we find for a
bunch of people living in the
rural areas.
And this is food, alcohol,
tobacco, education and health.
So what are your remarks when
you see these numbers?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the education
percentages.
Do those mean that we'd be
paying for tuition or
educational [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So this is only
education expenditure.
So this is tuition if the child
is in a private school
or if they get extra tuition,
which a lot of people in
developing countries do.
They get extra help at home.
This could be school uniform,
school books, boarding school
for kids who are in
boarding school.
Any education related
expenditure would be in there.
Yeah, Ben.
AUDIENCE: I guess a couple
confusions, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So in 2.1, Mexico
is spending more on alcohol
and tobacco than on education.
Spends very, very little
on health.
That doesn't mean people
are totally unhealthy.
But actually, Mexico has an
excellent health care system,
but basically is free
for most people.
And in all of the countries,
the share on alcohol and
tobacco tends to be at least
comparable to what we see for
education and health.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why don't the numbers
add up to 100%?
PROFESSOR: Because there are
other things you do with your
money other than food, alcohol,
education or health.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
PROFESSOR: Going to the movies,
putting some cloth on
your back, that kind of stuff.
If it adds up to more than 100,
we're in trouble, which
is quite possible.
But I hope not, I hope not.
I don't guarantee it, but
I hope that that kind of
mistakes would not always
send scrutiny.
Any other observation
on this table?
Let me ask one question then.
Do you think the share of the
budget on food is high or low?
AUDIENCE: High.
PROFESSOR: High, you think the
share of food is high?
Yes.
[INAUDIBLE].
Ben?
AUDIENCE: I mean, [INAUDIBLE],
I don't think you'd have much
wiggle room to spend your money
on other [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's about right.
Yeah, so the question is whether
it's high or low.
So one thing I should say is
that it's kind of viability.
It goes from pretty low in
India, 56%, to pretty high in
Timor, 77%.
Remember, this is all people who
are equally poor in term
of their ability to consume
things, because they're all
below a dollar a day at PPP.
They make very different
choices.
They are quite viable.
Whether it's high or low,
I think it's in
the eye of the beholder.
On the one hand, it's certainly
a high part of the
budget, compared to what
people spend, for
example, in the US.
On the other hand, if you
compare it with, for example,
what they spent on tobacco, even
on education, given that
a lot of these countries have
a free education system, the
education expenditure they are
making are extras, I'm sure
surely value extras.
But that means that there seems
to be actually some
wiggle room, that you could do
something about your food
budget and increase it without
sacrificing anything else
that's vital for the house.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question
about what you presented.
The people who spend
more on food, is
their nutrition better?
Or is it [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So that's an
excellent question.
We're going to look into that,
which is when you spend more
money on food, it could
be on more nutritious
food or more calories.
It could be on not so much
more nutritious food.
It could be on better
tasting food.
And the short answer is that
the two are happening.
I don't know whether it's true
at the country level.
For example, India is a country
that spends very
little on food and which has
probably the worst nutritional
stages for this group of people
within the world.
But at the individual level,
we're going to see that very
soon when people increase how
much money they spend on food,
they both get more food and
they get better food, more
expensive food for the calories
and the nutrition
they are getting.
So both things happen
together.
AUDIENCE: What is the
requirement for the
[INAUDIBLE]
children and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, this
is everyone.
This is everyone who lives
on less than a
dollar a day per capita.
So if there are five of
them, they are entire
budget divided by 5.
And if no one has any children,
then they won't
spend anything on education.
AUDIENCE: They migh have spent
quite a bit more on education.
PROFESSOR: This means that per
child, they spend a fair
amount on education.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is more expensive in South
Africa or Timor, so
[INAUDIBLE] basically be buying
the same quantity of
food to be spending more.
PROFESSOR: Right, so that's
an excellent point.
The point is in answer to the
unstated question, which is
what explains this variation
across countries, our first
possible explanation
is the relative
price of food is different.
So food could be relatively more
expensive in Timor Leste,
which is why people are spending
more money to get the
same thing.
What is interesting is that the
opposite seems to be true,
which is because India is a
very large economy that is
able to produce very many things
in India, the relative
price of things like toothbrush,
even DVDs,
cellphones--
that kind of things
relative to food--
is lower in India.
So one of the reasons why people
seem to be spending, or
one possible reason--
I'm not saying this
is a tirant.
But this is a conjecture, let's
say-- is one of the
reasons why people in India
spend much less on food and
more on other things compared to
people in Papua New Guinea,
is that there is nothing
to get in Papua New
Guinea except food.
So if you are poor, like
what can you buy?
Well, in India, you can buy
shampoo of this kind, and
everything is produced locally,
hence the relative
prices are lower.
So that's a possible explanation
for this pattern.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
different prices across
countries for food, I thought
that the one dollar a day
standard was in terms of
purchasing power, so
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: For your
entire budget.
So the one dollar a day standard
takes a basket of
consumption good.
Of course, food is an important
part o it, but there
is also other things that
people consume.
So one dollar a day takes
the basket of goods.
In fact, the way it's computed
here, it's 16
rupees a day, actually--
takes the basket of good that is
consumed by the poor rather
than your basket of good or my
basket of good, and price it
in the different places
and adjust with that.
So good plays an
important part.
But other things play as well.
And then within a single dollar
a day, it could be
that, say in India, for example,
food is relatively
expensive relative to other
things just because the other
things are so cheap
and available.
Yes, Eve.
AUDIENCE: Could it be that it's
hotter in India than the
other places, so in other places
people need to eat more
food to have more fat to
preserve heat, whereas in
India, they don't need to eat as
much food because it's hot
all the time?
PROFESSOR: So it could be.
It's a very interesting point,
and we are going
to make this point.
We are going to see this
point coming up in
another guide very soon.
The point is that we don't
know what's the calorie
requirement for a human being,
partly because it depends on
the climate and it depends
on what you are doing.
And it depends on how much
calories you are losing to
illnesses and other
things like that.
One piece of evidence that
suggests it's not the entire
story is that if it were the
case, if I looked at the size
of the Indian people compared
to the size of anyone else,
what should I see?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, in your
hypothesis where the
difference is due to the fact
that they need less calories
because it's warm, if everything
was explained here
by the fact that Indian people
don't need that much calorie
compare to--
see, all these countries
are warm.
But compared to South Africa,
South Africa is a bit more
temperate, so poor people in
South Africa need to eat a lot
because it's cold when it's
the winter there.
Then if all the differences in
calorie consumption were to be
explained by these needs, we
would find people whose
nutrition status would
be comparable.
So their height would be the
same and their weight
would be the same.
And in fact, Indian people are
very, very short and they are
very, very skinny.
Now you might say, yes,
but that's genetic.
It's just, like, Indian
people are short.
But that's actually not true,
because the children, when
Indian migrants come to the US,
they start eating US food,
their children are
still smaller.
But the children of
their children--
some of you might be that--
are exactly as tall
as anybody else.
So it suggests that the genetic
potential of Indian
people in term of height and
body size is no different than
that of anybody else.
But it's their nutritional
status that is different.
And that affects them directly,
and that affects
their children just because
of when you're in utero in
someone who doesn't eat enough,
you'll also be smaller.
For the longest time,
people said
Japanese people were short.
But it turns out that the height
in Japan are converging
to the height of everybody
else in the world.
So this is more of a nutrition
thing than all this cereal and
maize that we are consuming,
than a
genetic potential probably.
So going back to sort of the
two punch lines here--
one is that this is moving a
lot, which suggests that there
is some margin of choices, at
least in India, for example.
Second is we have this alcohol
and tobacco that we could, in
principle, get rid of.
And then all of that would
be extra calories.
So that suggests that this is
high, this is important.
But there seems to be some
amount of wiggle room take
Ben's word.
There is some amount of
wiggle room here.
And to look at other form of
wiggle room, so another way to
look at it is to look at this
question, which is what is the
elasticity of calorie
consumption with respect to
your income?
So this log per capita outlay
is some fancy way of saying
log per capita expenditure,
which is a good measure of
your wealth.
And what you can see
is that this is the
log per capita calorie.
This is looking at Maharashtra
in 1993.
India has grown a lot since
1993, but Maharashtra in 1993
was a pretty poor place.
And what you find is that as
people become richer, they do
consume more.
The slope of this line
is about 0.3.
And the slope of this line when
I run a regression of log
per capita calorie on log per
capita outlay, what is the
slope giving me?
The elasticity.
So whenever I go log log
regression, I get the
elasticity.
Interestingly, this is
not a regression.
I mean, this is a regression,
but not a linear regression.
This is a non parametric
regression, which means that
if the shape had been what I
told you it could be, which is
very high elasticity early on,
and then a lower one, so
something we would expect if we
were in the S shape world
of the elasticity being above
one for the poor and then
less, the way they have
estimated this regression
allows for this to
be the case.
But that's not what they find.
They find the elasticity of
1.5 pretty much constant
across the range in the data.
Now no one here is very rich, so
it's quite possible that it
starts going down here.
But the point is that even for
the very poorest, that
elasticity is not above one, so
even the very poorest have
an Engel curve phenomenon,
which is as they become
richer, they don't start eating
as much as possible,
eating the extra calories up.
They're eating, in terms of
calories, if I increase your
income by 10%, you increase
your calorie
consumption by 30%.
So these two first things
suggest that maybe this is
somewhat unlikely that there
would be this very strong S
shape, because otherwise people
would be behaving in a
very bizarre way.
So we've seen that.
So I think we've covered this.
So the calories increased with
overall consumption, but not
one for one.
When total expenditure
increased by 10%, the
consumption of calorie
increased by 3.5%.
So we have an Engel curve.
That is true for everyone.
So why is the slope of the Engel
curve less than one?
So what happens is what was
suggested earlier, which is
when people get a bit more
money, they do increase the
share of the budget going
to other things.
So the elasticity of overall
food expenditure
is less than one.
It's about 0.7.
So if I increase your budget by
10%, you increase your food
consumption by 7%.
And then it means you increase
something else more than
proportionally.
So maybe you start spending
money on the movies, which you
were not doing before.
So that's the first thing.
So 7% is not 3, though.
So what is the difference
between 7 and 3?
When I increase your budget by
10%, you increase your food
budget by 7%.
But your calories only
increase by 3.5.
So what happened in
the meantime?
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Maybe all your food
wasn't as high in calories.
PROFESSOR: They bought more
expensive food anyway.
Maybe because that food was
yummier, maybe because it was
more nutritious, but certainly
more expensive food.
So what happens is that when
you spend more on food, you
start buying more expensive
calories and you do that in
various ways.
You start eating meat instead
of eating cereals, and you
start eating more expensive
cereals instead of the course
cereals you were
eating before.
And even within the more
expensive cereals, rice for
example, you buy more
expensive rice.
So all of this margin happens.
And we can see it here
in the table.
We can see this is Maharashtra,
1983.
These are the poorest
10% and the top 10%.
We can see that the poorest 10%
spent 46% of their budget
on cereals, and the
top 10%, 31%.
And if we look at meat, meat
is 8.5% for the poorest and
12% for the richest.
Things like are constant,
however, in terms of fraction
of the budget is sugar.
And the sugar actually goes
down 7.425%, and oil.
That remains about the same.
The fraction of the budget spent
on oil is 9% for both.
But you get cereal going down,
and you get meat going up.
And the price per calorie of
cereal is much cheaper
compared to the price
per calorie of meat.
And now within cereal, people
who are poor spend 9% of their
budget on the rice.
And the rich are spending
almost 11% of
their budget on rice.
And then the price of rice is
also cheaper than the price of
other things.
Price is more expensive, sorry,
than other things like
the course cereal.
And even within rice, the
poor are buying cheaper
rice than the rich.
The poor are spending 18 paise
per calorie for the rice, and
one rupee per calorie for
the richer people.
So all of this margin happen,
which again suggests that
there is some amount
of flexibility.
Because otherwise, what you
would do is to, within the
same budget, continue to eat
the same thing, but more of
the same thing.
So if you were at subsistence
level, the share of your
calories that comes from
the staple food
would remain constant.
And it's only after you've
reached some level of
subsistence that you would
say, now I can
start eating more meat.
It's more expensive,
but it's yummier.
And so the fact that even for
these relatively poor people
who see that the share of
calories that comes from rice
declines is an indication that
they probably see themselves
having some margin of choice.
So even among the very poor
people, an increase in
economic well being has
positive, but not a huge,
impact on calories consumed.
So you take the poorest person
here and you increase their
budget by 10%, they will
increase their calories by
3.5%, partly because there are
other things they like to do,
partly because within
food, they also like
to eat better food.
So that brings us to this Jensen
and Miller idea, which
is the idea of a Giffen good.
So what's a Giffen good?
AUDIENCE: It's a good that
when the price increases,
there's an increase in demand.
PROFESSOR: When the price
increase, there is
an increase in demand.
That's right.
Why is that surprising?
AUDIENCE: Because generally
the demand curves--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Generally as the price
increases, there's a
decrease in the demand
for the quantity.
PROFESSOR: Generally, we
think of the demand
curve as looking down.
So if there is an increase
in the price, you
decrease your demand.
So why is it not a violation
of everything
we know about economics?
AUDIENCE: Because if the price
of some good increases, then
you wouldn't be able to
substitute out [INAUDIBLE]
pretty easily.
So the example of rice and
meat-- if the price of rice
increases, then in order to get
the calories you need, you
might have to buy more rice
and just stop buying meat.
PROFESSOR: Right, Mr. Giffen is
referred to by who for the
first time?
Are there some writings
by Mr. Giffen?
AUDIENCE: Indiana Jones.
PROFESSOR: Indiana Jones--
but before that.
So Mr. Giffen-- we have no
writing from him directly, but
he was referred to
by Adam Smith.
And Adam Smith gives
the example
of potatoes in Ireland.
The price of potatoes goes up,
but potatoes is such an
important part of the budget
that when the price of
potatoes goes up, it does an
income effect, so that is
always true.
When the price of a good goes
up, it has an income effect
and it has a substitution
effect.
What do we know about the
substitution effect?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Generally when the
price of one good goes up,
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so when the
price of a good goes up, you
substitute to another good.
So the substitution effect
is always negative.
But the income effect can be
either positive or negative.
So the income effect--
in what case is it positive?
So for example, if you look at
iPod consumption, would that
tend to have a positive
income effect or a
negative income effect?
So the goods that are more like
luxury goods, that are a
bit expensive, will have
positive income effect,
meaning as you become richer,
you will consume more of them.
The goods that are cheaper and
that are not particularly
desirable will have negative
income effect.
For example, think about
your own budget.
As you become richer, maybe
you are going to buy more
orange juice.
That is a positive
income effect.
Maybe you are going to get
fewer macaroni and cheese
pre-packed.
That has a negative
income effect.
So the income effect could be
positive or could be negative.
It's positive if it's
a normal good.
It's negative if it's
an inferior good.
So now something like potato is
presumably an inferior good.
That's not something
people love.
It's something that as they
become richer, they will try
and substitute to
another thing.
So the question is whether the
income effect of an inferior
good like potato is so large--
not only it's negative, but it
is so large that it out does
the substitution effect.
So if the income effect is so
large that it more than
compensates for the substitution
effect, then you
might be getting a
different good.
So that is the story of the
potato famine, which is
possibly apocryphal,
the story being the
price of potato increases.
But that makes people poorer,
so that actually increases
their consumption of potatoes,
because they stop eating meat,
and they eat only potatoes
because they have no money
left to buy any meat.
So this is a different good.
So until this paper, I think
there was a strong suspicion
among economists that
different goods--
actually, they didn't exist,
but they were a nice
theoretical possibility, but
that in practice, you don't
see a good where the income
effect is so large that it
outdoes the substitution effect,
so that if you become
richer, you eat fewer
potatoes.
But if the price of
potatoes declines,
you eat more potatoes.
So this is the story.
So a staple food that
constitutes a large part of
the budget, like potatoes for
Irish famine or the example
they have in China are what?
AUDIENCE: These were two
provinces in the North
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Wheat and rice.
So these are foods which are a
fairly large part of the food
budget and a fairly large part
of the overall budget.
So this is a good confident
for a different good.
Because for the income effect to
have any chance to be large
enough, it has to be something
that takes a large part of
your budget.
So that's why they decided
on this thing.
So the first thing they've done
is they looked at these
two provinces and they observed
that, for example, in
a rice consuming region, they
observed that in cities where
the price of rice is higher,
people consume more rice.
And first, they are very happy,
and they said oh, we
have found our Giffen good.
But then they get depressed and
they realize maybe it is
not a Giffen good.
So why do they conclude
that it doesn't give
them a Giffen good?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is it because the price is
higher that people consume
more rice, which would make it
an incident? or is it that
people consume more rice, so
the price becomes higher?
PROFESSOR: Right,
we don't know.
We are trying to trace
a demand curve.
But if we only observe prices
and quantity, we might be
tracing the supply curve.
So we don't know whether we have
traced the demand curve
or the supply curve.
And this would be the normal
shape for a supply curve.
So this is exactly the same type
of problems that we were
facing when we were trying to
look at the effect of malaria
prices on bednets, which is if
we just look at the variation
in the world, there is the
effect that we are trying to
identify, and there is a
possible of a reverse
causality, in this case, very
clear, which is we also have a
supply curve that we are
trying to trace.
So that's why they decided
that's not working.
So what did they decide to do?
AUDIENCE: They subsidized
rice and wheat.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly, what they
decided to do is to run the
maize experiment where they
subsidized the price of rice
in the rice consuming region
and wheat in the wheat
consuming region at
various levels.
I think there are three
levels of subsidies.
So they take a sample
of households.
They distribute a voucher for
the reduced price of rice in
Hunan and reduced price of wheat
in Gangsu to a random
sub sample for more than a
month's supply every month.
They made sure that
the household
wouldn't extend them.
Otherwise, what would be a
problem if households started
trading them?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly, in
particular you try
to reduce the price.
But if you give voucher and
people start exchanging them,
think of food stamps when people
sell their food stamps.
When they sell their food
stamps, they are getting
money, which is--
I mean, it's not bad.
But why do we think
it's an issue?
And why would there
be a theoretical
issue in their cases?
AUDIENCE: Essentially, the price
of the rice would need
to be changed.
PROFESSOR: It wouldn't
be changing.
So the people would get their
voucher, and then they would
sell it to someone.
So they would get
money instead.
And then they would, with that
many, perhaps buy some rice
and wheat and buy some
other things as well.
So their experiment where they
tried to change the price of
rice or wheat would end up just
changing their income
without changing the price.
Because the marginal price that
they are facing once they
have sold their voucher is the
same, except they now have
more money.
So now all they would identify
is the income effect.
And of course, the income
effect would be negative
because that's an
inferior good.
So they would be finding
a Giffen good.
But that would not
be a real one.
That would be a fake one due to
the fact that their price
experiment would be transformed
into an income
experiment.
So it's very important for
them to keep the price
experiment in tact.
So they tried to do that and
they tried to argue in the
paper and in the post that you
read in Freakonomics that
they've done this properly.
And after six months, they came
back, and then they asked
detailed questions about the
consumption of rice, wheat and
other things.
So what do they find?
So I'm going to show you the
regression table which gives
us the results directly and
explain to you what's in the
regression table.
So it's a long table.
But for now, focus on
the first column.
So what they regress is the
percent increase in rice
consumption over the
percent subsidy.
There are three groups
of subsidies.
I was looking everywhere in the
paper for you to have the
three prices and the three
reductions so that I could
plot them, but they
were not there.
So this is the overall result.
So basically, the way you
read this graph--
it's saying that your
consumption of rice reduces by
23.5% when the subsidy
increases by 100%.
It's directly a percentage
of a percentage.
So your consumption of rice
reduces in percentage about a
quarter of the reduction
in price.
So the important thing
here is, of
course, that it's negative.
And below the coefficient
here, you get
the standard error.
So the coefficient is 0.235.
The standard error 0.14.
If you divide by one the other,
you get the familiar T
statistics.
This one is above 1.7, so this
means this is significant at
10% level, which tells
you that this is not
entirely due to chance.
This negative is
not some fluke.
It is something which is
indeed significantly
different from 0.
So that's what they
find for Hunan.
And then they find the opposite
for seafood, where
the elasticity of seafood
consumption with respect to
the price of rice is
very positive.
So what happened in
their experiment--
this is your typical Giffen
good behavior--
is the price of rice increases,
but increases
because rice is such an
important part of your budget.
It amounts to increasing
your income.
And because of this increase in
your income, you feel that
you can now get more of your
calories from shrimps and
fewer from food.
So that's for Hunan.
So this is the explanation.
And for Gansu, we have a
positive elasticity.
So it means that wheat doesn't
appear to be a
Giffen good in Gansu.
It appears to be an
inferior good.
It increased less than one for
one, but in fact, it's not
significantly positive.
But it's certainly
not negative.
And they explain why they find
a different result in a
different place.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: What prevented then
from just [INAUDIBLE] rice
they got to give more money
by substituting goods?
PROFESSOR: Right, so they
tried to stop that.
But we don't know for sure
that they succeeded.
What they were very worried
about is the
resale of the voucher.
And their view then is once you
had resold the voucher,
then you wouldn't have
resold the rice.
And what they did after that
is they did a survey.
So the data here doesn't come
from the administrative data
of what was sold in the shop.
The survey comes from what
people consumed at
the end of the day.
So to the extent that people
didn't lie to them, this is
the actually consumption.
So it could still be the case
that they bought the rice.
They sold the rice.
They bought the rice with the
voucher because they couldn't
exchange the voucher.
But then, they went to the
trouble of selling the rice.
And that's why it's just an
income effect that we are
estimating, which is
why it's negative.
They tried to argue that it
didn't happen, but that's, of
course, a key concept.
So what do they say about wheat,
that why did the wheat
show them a different good for
the wheat, but they have one
for the rice?
AUDIENCE: Because people aren't
eating wheat itself.
They're eating wheat products,
like noodles.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, you are
saying that it's not their own
group, that people rice.
They don't buy big packets of
wheat, so that it was kind of
the wrong idea.
This, of course, has implication
for nutrition, and
in particular for a very
frequent policy that we find
in developing world, which is
food price's subsidy for
greater nutrition.
So for example, in Indonesia,
we have the ration program.
If you remember, in Pak Solhin's
stories, he got some
free rice from the
ration program.
In India, India just introduced
the Right to Food
Act and a subsidy scheme
for rice in
rice consuming regions.
So India has something called
a public distribution system
where they distribute food to
households at reduced prices,
to poor households at
reduced prices.
Egypt spent something like 3% of
its GDP on food subsidies.
So food subsidies is a very
important part of help to the
poor in developing countries.
It's also a very important
part of our--
our meaning the US--
aid to poor countries is in the
form of food aid, directly
food which we send to
poor countries.
Why are we spending a lot of our
aid in terms of food aid?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
lot of food [INAUDIBLE].
It's easier for us to just
take that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, so part of the
reason why a lot of our aid is
in the form of food aid
is that it's also
aid for our own farmers.
And it's a way of kind of
buying the [INAUDIBLE]
and sending them out.
So when the weather has been
good in the US and the harvest
is very big, a lot more food
aid is being spent
all over the world.
But with that aside, this is a
policy that many countries
have to try to subsidize
the price of food.
But if we have something like
the Giffen good, what may
happen if you make the price
of the staple less high, if
you make the price of
the staple lower?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Then they'll spend
their income on other sorts of
stuff, not on the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, we might find
that something like this
happens, which is the price
of rice has now gone down.
Instead of eating more rice,
you ate less rice and more
shrimps and maybe also
more cellphones.
So if rice is indeed a Giffen
good, the increase in the
calories you are getting from a
decline in the price of rice
might actually not
be very high.
In fact, it might even
be negative.
Because if the income effect is
sufficiently large, it made
outdo, again, the
price effect.
And we might find that as we
make food cheaper, people eat
less instead of eating more.
And that's exactly what they
found in Hunan where rice was
a Giffen good.
They find that as you decrease
the price of rice, people eat
fewer calories, not more.
So this would be the very
standard poor price policy in
your average developing
countries, to try to subsidize
the staple.
And the justification of this
policy will typically be in
the form of we need to
increase the calorie
consumption because people are
trapped in poverty trap like
our friend, Pak Solhin.
But in fact, if you look at this
for this urban household
in China, you find the opposite,
which is subsidizing
the price of rice actually
leads to
fewer calories consumed.
And it's not because people gain
in terms of other micro
nutrients, though we
don't have all
the other micro nutrient.
But we get fewer portions
being consumed as well.
So this is what they find
in Hunan, but they
don't have it in Gansu.
So it's not to say that
it happens necessarily
everywhere, but it is something
that might happen.
So it is not a total given that
a reduction in the price
of food will lead to an
increase in nutrition.
On the bright side, it also
means that it's not
necessarily a given that the
current increase in the food
prices that we are observing
will lead to people eating
fewer calories.
Because it might have this
progress effect of making them
poorer and therefore leading
them to eat more of calories.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
one way [INAUDIBLE]
food [INAUDIBLE].
Because, for example, if you eat
shrimps, shrimps may not
be very calorie rich.
In India, people eat
a lot of lentils.
And the next thing that they eat
to rice is durum, which is
actually full of protein.
So eating less rice, and if they
spend more on protein,
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so this is,
of course, completely
dependent on what you
substitute with.
If you substitute rice with
lentils, actually it might be
more nutrition, and more iron,
more nutrition, et cetera.
So we might find an increase in
nutrition due to subsidy in
the price the rice.
So the only point here was
not to say that it
has to be the case.
It was to say that it doesn't
have to be the case that
subsidizing the price the rice
will lead to more rice and
more calories being consumed.
Now let's look at India,
precisely.
So before that, there is
something that should surprise
you in when you put together
this Jenson and Miller result
and what we had before
in India.
We found that a household that
are 10% richer eat about 3.5
more calories.
But the Jenson and
Miller result--
what does it suggest about
the income effect?
We are finding that when the
price of rice decreases, you
eat less, not more.
What the income effect
has to be?
AUDIENCE: It's negative.
PROFESSOR: It has
to be negative.
So on the one hand, I showed you
positive income effect--
maybe not very large, but
certainly positive for India.
On the other hand, I'm showing
you price effect in China
which suggest that the income
effect has to be negative, and
in fact, very negative.
So how can this be?
How can we have the two
things together?
So the first thing is that in
India, we were comparing
different households.
We were not comparing the
same household to
which I give more money.
And different households
are different.
Maybe they're households
that are a bit richer.
They are also more educated and
they understand the value
of nutrition, and that's
why they eat more.
So the idea in experiment would
be to give people a
little bit more money, really
literally do that and see
whether they spend this
money on food or not.
And that would allow us to
estimate the income effect.
To my knowledge, no
one has done that.
It's a little bit difficult
to parachute [INAUDIBLE]
drops of money on people--
not impossible, but it's not
been done, I don't think.
So what we have when we looked
at the India curve, we find
that people who have more
money eat more.
But it may be because they have
different tastes or it
might be because they eat more,
and therefore they're
more productive, therefore they
have more money, so the
opposite relationship.
So that may be an
underestimate.
That positive estimate, which
was already not that high of
the income effect, might have
been an over estimate.
And one thing that's
suggested--
and it goes back to
[? Swati's ?] point earlier--
is when we plug the Engel curve
over time in India, we
see two interesting things.
Number one, all of the Engel
curve for the rural areas are
above the Engel curve
for the urban areas.
Why do you think that
would be the case?
AUDIENCE: The work in the rural
area is much more labor
intensive, so you need
to eat more to
have physical strength.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, the work
in rural area is more
intensive, and so they
need more calories.
So this is interesting that
you are making this point,
because this is the point you
were making earlier about
maybe the needs of calorie in
South Africa are bigger
because it's colder.
So that's the first
things we notice.
So this we can explain.
And what's the other interesting
trend in this
picture is that over time, the
Engel curves are falling down.
People are eating less, and
less, and less for the same
level of income.
So what happened in India over
time is that, of course,
people got richer.
So if the Engel curves had been
stable, they would have
eaten more.
But because the Engel curves are
also falling down at the
same time, what happened over
time is that people are moving
first across to another Engel
curve and then up along an
Engel curve.
So take someone who would
be at a log income of 5.
15 years later, they have a log
income maybe of 5.5, but
the Engel curve have
also moved.
Take someone who is at 5, and
then 15 years later, they
would be, let's say, at 6.
But now we need to find the 6 on
the much lower Engel curve.
So instead of eating more, as
they would have if the Engel
curve had become stable, we find
that people in India eat
less and less.
So over time, the poor in India
are eating less and less
instead of eating more and more,
which does suggest some
negative income elasticity for
the country as a whole.
The country is becoming richer
and those people are becoming
richer, but they are eating
less and less.
So this now starts to make sense
with the two results,
where maybe the income
elasticity of food
consumption--
not only it's not above one,
which is what we would have in
a poverty trap kind of a
world, but it might be
negative, which is as people
become richer, they-- a funny
thing-- eat fewer calories.
So if we look at nutrition in
India, we have a pretty
interesting phenomenon, which is
this is the share of people
who are eating below 2,100
in urban areas and
2,400 in rural areas.
This is the number of calories
they consume per head.
Why are these interesting
thresholds?
Yeah.
You had a question or you
were just moving?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was going
to ask [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Go ahead, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if that couldn't just be
explained because of inflation
and not necessarily for a
negative effect.
PROFESSOR: Very good,
I could be that the
price of food has changed.
People have become richer, but
food is now more expensive.
Remember, it has to be relative
prices, because
people have become richer
in real term.
Even corrected for inflation,
India is richer now.
And there are also fewer
poor people.
But it could be that food prices
increase relative to
other things.
And that's actually not
the case until 2005.
And then it became very much
the case after 2005.
But these results are until
2005, where the relative price
of food were relatively
stable.
That's a very good point.
2,100, 2,400.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I was just
wondering the calculation that
was done for people who are
doing sort of intensive labor,
how many calories they would
need as a bare minimum to be
able to succeed in that?
PROFESSOR: Again, we don't
really know how many calories
we need, but this is
what the Indian
government says you need.
And maybe they get it a bit
wrong, because this is the
fraction of people in rural
area who are getting
less than they need.
So it's very high.
Yet these people are
still all alive.
But what is striking is that
this is increasing both in
rural area and in urban area,
but even more in rural area.
So one first explanation was
yours, is maybe it's the
relative price of food.
That would be true after 2005,
but not until 2005.
What could be other
explanation?
AUDIENCE: Maybe a lot of poor
people have come from rural
areas, and very poor
[INAUDIBLE]
rural areas and then sort of
broke up into rural areas
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that's a
very good suggestion.
Maybe that the people who are
in rural area now are the
very, very poor, so they are
relatively poorer, so we get
more of them who are
eating less.
And the urban area also getting
poorer, because the
people from the rural
area move to them.
That's a very good suggestion,
a composition effect.
That probably doesn't explain
it, because if you look at
that overall consumption per
capita of these people, are
the function of people who live
below a dollar a day,
that is going down here
and down here.
So that's probably not--
AUDIENCE: There has been
more technology.
They're going to spend other
money on other stuff.
PROFESSOR: Right, so this would
be another explanation,
which is the similar explanation
from what we are
seeing on the wall, which
is there are more
and more things available.
In particular, one thing that
has clearly happened is the
advent of cell phone.
And so now cell phones weren't
there, and now they are there.
In India, you can get a cell
phone and airtime everywhere.
And so that's one thing.
So more things become available,
very good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think this might
be what you meant, but
technology that might make the
work easier, so you require
fewer calories because the
work is not as difficult.
PROFESSOR: Right, this is not
what she meant just now, but
that's what she meant earlier.
So I was surprised she is not
making this point again.
But that's exactly a very good
point, which is maybe these
are what the Indian government
says, but who
knows what they know.
And maybe the calorie
requirements have changed.
One of the reasons would be that
you're less likely to do
back breaking work, or maybe
because there is more
irrigation, there is more
mechanisation of agriculture.
People are less likely
to be in agriculture,
even in rural areas.
What would be another reason
why the calorie requirement
would have gone down?
So one is clearly, you are
less likely to work.
What competes with calories
with you?
AUDIENCE: Are you talking
about worms and health?
PROFESSOR: Worms, and health and
diarrhea, and other nice
things like that.
Generally being sick consumes
a lot of calories.
And so one thing that has
happened in India is drinking
water has become more available
and cleaner, so
people are much less
likely to be sick.
Another thing that uses a lot of
calories is being pregnant,
and you have many fewer
children being born.
So that's also compete
less for calories.
So one possible reason for all
of these, for these changes,
is that the calorie requirements
have just changed
and people are staying at the
same level as before.
They spend less.
And they are used to a
particular level, so they just
stay there, and it costs them
less money than before.
So this leads us to a
possibility for why people are
not easy more generally.
Maybe they're not eating because
that's not such a
great investment.
And so when we went through
out little theory section
here, we said that if you happen
to be right here in the
capacity curve, it's very
valuable for you to eat.
But if, in the real world,
the effect of calories on
productivity is not that loud,
then you might as well do
something else with
your money.
And in fact, what we find when
we look at the effect is that
this is the effect of calories
consumed on your productivity
if you're a farmer
in Sierra Leone.
And it's hard to find a job that
requires less strength
than being a farmer
in Sierra Leone.
And what you find is that
while it is increasing,
certainly, people
who eat more--
this is your calorie
consumption, and this is how
productive you are--
people are more productive
when they eat more.
But what's the shape
of the curve?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's our inverted
L shape, and it's not
greater than one.
So now we finally can answer
the question that
you asked ages ago.
There is no real sign.
This is probably the most
favorable case, which is why I
put it on the board.
There is no real sign that this
phenomenon that you need
to eat enough calories,
otherwise you can't be
productive enough to do anything
is really there.
So in the very short run,
everything starts to fit,
which is people don't really
need the extra calories that
much, because the extra
calories makes them
productive, but not that
much more productive.
Hence, they are not
eating them.
And in fact, we see over time
that they are eating less and
less of the calories
because they need
less and less of them.
And they have a level of
strength that allows them to
do their day to day work, and
with the rest of their money,
they do other things, and that
makes now perfect sense.
So in terms of policies,
what does it mean?
Well in term of policies, it
means that policies that are
going to insist that the big
problem is starvation in terms
of not eating enough grain
are probably going to be
misleading, and are probably
going to lead to a
fair amount of waste.
So in summary, at the maximum
when your income today
increases by 10%, your calorie
consumption increase by 3.5%.
That's what we saw in India,
and that's almost surely a
wild over estimate.
But let's say that it's
a maximum possible.
And then your productivity--
you multiply that by another
4%, so when your income
increases by 10%, your income
increases by 1.4% tomorrow.
That would be the S shape,
except it's not S, because
there is no point where it would
cause the 45 degree line
from below, because the
elasticity is much, much less
than one instead of
being above one.
So we don't have a place where
the curve is crossing the 45
degree line from below.
The curve is just not steep
enough to create a poverty
trap from this phenomenon.
Just to be sure that you don't
go away thinking everything is
well, this may be very different
from other things
than calories, for
example iron.
And this may be very different
for children, because the
investment in a child, the
investment you're making at
one specific time is going to
help them for their entire
life instead of just
for tomorrow.
So what we are going to do on
Thursday is look at what I
call the hidden trap, which
is that there might be a
nutrition productivity poverty
trap, but it's not in the
usual sense where we
were looking for.
It's in these more subtle
things, nutrients,
micronutrients, children's
nutrition,
pregnant women's nutrition.